-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Jake Tapper.
As we mentioned, you're doing
your show at 9:00 p.m.
through the midterms.
-Yeah.
-This is going to be --
You know, I think people
have said this a lot.
This is the biggest midterm
in our lifetime.
This does seem like a big one,
and I'm wondering
how you approach covering it
because it seems like
you have one party
digging their heels in,
in advance,
about, "This election
might be stolen from us again."
-Yeah. In fact, Kari Lake,
the Republican nominee
in Arizona,
has basically said
she's only going to accept
the results if she wins.
-Yep.
-Which is an interesting
guiding principle.
-A nice piece of honesty, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, it's weird.
I mean, there's a bunch
of election liars,
election deniers who are
in competitive races
and could very likely win,
Kari Lake among them.
In Pennsylvania and Michigan
and Arizona.
And it's something
that I think people in the media
just need to be honest
and up-front about.
-What about how the returns
come in?
Because I think --
You've obviously been through
so many of these election
nights, and sometimes
certain places report early,
and, you know, all of a sudden,
you have a candidate
who is leading 80-20.
But people there,
people in the room know
this isn't
a real number yet, right?
We have -- The bluer areas
of the state haven't reported.
Like, do you have
long discussions about
how you put up the results?
-Well, when the results
come in,
we try to make sure
people understand
these are early ballots
or this state
has these kinds of rules.
You know,
it's very frustrating for me
because I'm from Pennsylvania,
and the legislature there,
which is Republican-led,
will not let the election boards
not only count them
ahead of time,
the votes that come in in early
voting or absentee ballots,
but even prepare them,
meaning you can't even take them
out of the envelope.
So a whole bunch of votes
will not be counted that day
just because
of how the rules are.
And yet people
will then complain
about how inefficient
the system is
as if there's some hijinks
going on.
And Trump took advantage of this
in 2020.
He made it very clear he was
going to declare victory early,
knowing that there were
still going to be
millions of votes to be counted.
-I want to ask
what your take is --
Obviously very early days of
Elon Musk in charge of Twitter.
But we've already seen a few
things where he's magnifying --
he's magnifying news stories
that are sort of unsourced
and poorly reported.
-They're not "unsourced
and poorly reported."
They're nuts!
-Yeah.
-They're crazy.
-Thank you.
-He -- Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, but it's --
There's bad journalism,
and then there's crazy, right?
-Right.
-I mean, this is crazy.
So, Hillary Clinton cited
something about the attack
on Nancy Pelosi's husband being
due to right-wing rhetoric,
and isn't that unfortunate,
et cetera?
And Elon Musk wrote back to her
on Twitter,
"There might be
something more --
a little bit more to the story."
And linked to a website
that literally --
Well, that had a smear campaign
about Paul Pelosi,
but, more importantly,
had declared
that Hillary Clinton died
in 2016...
-Yeah.
-...and that a body double
had actually debated
Donald Trump.
That was the --
That was the source.
That's the source material
that we're dealing with here.
-So it's actually good that
Elon said there might be more
to the story than you think...
if you are who you say you are.
-Right. Right.
"Hillary Clinton."
-But I think -- Right.
That's the scary thing
about this early approach,
is it does seem as though
he likes to throw things out
and say,
"Just worth mullin' over."
-Yeah.
-And that is not very helpful
as far as moving forward
the political discourse.
-Yeah, look, I'm generally
on the freer-speech debate,
that the solution to speech
you don't like is more speech.
But generally speaking,
the idea that not only
was he allowing this
to be on the platform,
which you can make a decision
about that one way or the other,
that he was actually
pushing it out as a guy
with 110 million followers
on Twitter
is not cause for confidence
about what the platform's
gonna be like in the future.
But we'll see.
It's early days yet, early days.
-It is early days. I think
he's gonna turn it around.
[ Laughter ]
-You're not even on it
that much anymore.
-Look, I'm not going to pay
20 bucks a month
for a blue checkmark.
Are you kidding me?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look. I am --
Let me explain why.
I have a severe
gambling problem.
[ Laughter ]
I want to talk about this,
not to --
-Yeah.
-This is a very serious
and incredibly well-reported
piece of journalism
that you have
a family connection to.
So, this is a story
about a young man
who was convicted for a crime
that he very likely
didn't commit.
But the one thing you make clear
in the story
is, whether you think
he committed the crime or not,
no one would agree that he got
good legal representation.
-He had a horrible lawyer.
My dad was his pediatrician.
This is C.J.
C.J. Rice was 17.
C.J. had been shot, and my dad
saw him in his pediatric office
in South Philadelphia,
and C.J. could barely walk.
Five days later,
there was another shooting,
a horrible thing,
and I think it's kind of shady,
but ultimately somebody said
that C.J. did it,
even though the shooters
had been seen running.
And C.J., my dad, other people
who knew him thought,
"Well, there's no way they're
going to convict him of this
or even charge him for it.
He can barely walk,
much less run."
-He turned himself in.
-Because he was so confident
that based on the fact
that he could not run,
this would be a situation
where they would just let him
walk out of the police station.
-Right, and his mom worked
for the District Attorney's
office, et cetera.
He gave them his phone,
thinking,
"Well, they're clearly
going to check to see
that my phone was actually
in West Philadelphia
that day, not South Philadelphia
where the shooting was."
But none of that happened,
and instead he didn't get a --
He wasn't lucky enough
to get a public defender.
He's poor, so he couldn't afford
a good attorney
that you or I would have
been able to afford.
He didn't get a public defender,
which are generally pretty good
lawyers, public defenders.
He had a court-appointed
attorney,
and some of them are great.
But the records, statistically
and according to studies,
is much worse, and she was just
a horrible lawyer, horrible.
And one instance after another,
she failed him,
making -- you know,
having it be in juvenile court
because he was 17,
going to the crime scene,
challenging
the one piece of evidence
against him over and over.
And going through this case,
which my dad asked me to
look into after years of trying
to get him out of prison,
it really just opened
my eyes about how --
I mean, we know it
intellectually,
but there really are just
two systems of justice,
one for people
who can afford it --
I would never have even been
charged with this crime,
and if I had been,
I would have gotten a lawyer
who would have gotten it
thrown out of court.
But this kid, you know,
he got the bad end of the stick
when it comes
to this sort of thing.
And he couldn't afford
a good lawyer,
and he had a horrible one.
And now he's just in prison
for 30 to 60 years for a crime
in which nobody
was even seriously wounded,
much less killed.
And it's just --
it's not justice.
And so, you know, I hear a lot
about crime on TV ads,
and, you know, I'll be doing
a piece about it on my show.
But, you know, the idea
that anytime anybody challenges
a conviction
that they're "soft on crime" --
I'm not soft on crime.
I want anybody guilty
of a shooting offense
in jail -- in prison.
But I don't think he did it,
and that means
the people who did do it,
they're still out there.
-Well, it's a really wonderful
piece of reporting.
The connection to your father
and the role he played,
the really noble role he played,
it should be noted, as well,
makes for great reading.
Thank you for being here.
It's always a pleasure
to see you.
-So good to see you in person.
Yeah, thank you.
-You guys, that's Jake Tapper.
"CNN Tonight with Jake Tapper"
airs nightly on CNN
through the midterms,
and his cover story
for "The Atlantic" is out now.
We'll be right back
with Sheryl Lee Ralph.